[music]
All right, we're really excited to be
here today. Um, and we have a great
turnout. So, I'm very excited to welcome
David and very look uh look very much
looking forward to this conversation.
Um, I think there's so much that we can
learn from Shaun. I think they have a
very unique positioning in this uh
physical AI ecosystem. So, just to
start, um, David, I'd love to just ask
you a little bit about where do you see
the physical AI landscape moving today?
Um, and what do you think is actually
driving the shifts today?
>> Yeah, I guess it's no secret it's moving
fast and it seems every day that it's
moving faster. And so uh we see that um
every day more and more opportunities
come up more and more uh opportunities
where we can get involved not only as
someone who is delivering components but
someone who is also using these physical
AI robotics inside of our plants. So
these two areas kind of come together
and it every day it gets faster. M so I
really want to dive into more um about
what Schaefer is doing and I think the
thing that really draws my attention is
that you have a really rich history of
innovation and technological development
that's actually spanned over 80 years
and when we think about companies today
we're often thinking about companies
that have emerged in the last decade or
even in the last few years that are just
starting to build and innovate. Um but
because of this rich technology that you
already have, how much of that do you
think has been a key driver in terms of
you being able to make this pivot uh
leverage your existing capabilities and
really provide an early entry point uh
into the physical AI space.
>> Yeah, it's it's it's a great point. So
it it really is an interesting um
experience uh having this 80 years
having all of this DNA and then trying
to harness it. As I mentioned before,
this whole physical AI is accelerating.
So what we have to do is be able to
extract and utilize the resources the
competencies that have built Shuffler up
over these 80 years and we have to do
that at a fast speed. If if you have all
these competencies and you can't
leverage that at a fast speed then it
doesn't do us any good. So that's one of
the things we spend a lot of time on is
yes we have this innovation yes we have
this manufacturing huge manufacturing
footprint with over a 100 plants
globally
>> all of this resources we have to harness
this in a fast way and so it's really
flexible communication it actually
starts with how we are set up inside of
our company so my my group does not
belong to the automotive side it does
not belong to the industrial side it's
separated out and we report to the top
of the house so everything is done with
agility and speed in Right.
>> So, it feels like it's very
strategically important for Shaer to go
into the physical AI space. Um, and
you're already doing a lot of work with
humanoid robots. Can you tell me a bit
more about why you think it's just so
strategically important and maybe what
you're looking to be able to achieve um
by being that early entrant?
>> Yeah, I think first of all um from top
of the house on down uh our CEO and the
executive board is very bullish on
physical AI. We see that is it a need uh
whether it starts with lack of a human
workforce that we will have. We we
actually have
>> issues in in parts of the world today
finding workers to work on our our
factories. And so that is an immediate
need that we have and that is helping
push us into wanting to deploy these.
And then on the component uh side uh we
see this as a natural pivot. We do
actuators today. We do bearings. We do
transmissions, e- motors, controllers.
We have all of this technology inhouse
for automotive or industrial and it's a
natural pivot then to carry this over
into the physical AI space.
>> I think the actuators component is very
interesting because you're actually
building a lot of the components and
actually working with a lot of what
people perceive to be the leading
humanoid companies um in the world. Um
can you tell me a bit more about what
you think some of those technical
challenges are that they're facing today
and maybe um the role that you're
playing in actually helping address
those technical challenges? Yeah, I I
think the big one out there and it's the
elephant in the room if we use a term
out out of America is is scaling. So
it's nice today everything is built more
or less like prototypes. It's tested in
labs and that will change uh with the
training with the AI improving uh that
we will be able to deploy these much
faster and if we want to deploy these we
will need technologies manufacturing
technologies that enable scaling and you
won't be able to put in we say football
fields worth of machining equipment. you
will not find the machines and so you
have to do something different and
that's where we get into let's form
parts instead of always machine them and
that takes seconds instead of minutes to
to do the machinings and so that's
really the space that chefller wants to
play is is how can we scale and that's
one of the biggest challenges we face
>> so I think you touched on the fact that
we need to get from you know prototype
into production and I definitely see
that as being one of the biggest
challenges in physical AI as well so
everyone is building building building
um but you know facing challenges once
you actually start to scale in
deployment um are you able to share a
bit more about Stafler and some of the
use cases that you're working on and how
you're starting to put this uh into
production or how some of your customers
are starting to do this um and you know
maybe from there uh share a bit more
about how you think this ecosystem looks
like in terms of what needs to happen to
really actually go from being in the lab
to out there in the real world and
delivering ROI.
>> Yeah. So one of the first things we
learned and and it was one of the first
things that kind of smacked us in the
face is you just have to start. So you
should do some upfront work and what we
did is we identified use cases inside of
our factories and we came up with six
different use cases that is used all of
these six use cases are used in most of
our 100 manufacturing plants. What we
wanted to stay away from is one unique
maybe cool uh use case that only one
plant in the world could use and that
just doesn't make sense. So once we have
the use cases, you have to then dive in,
find the right partners and we found a
number of these partners globally to
where you can cooperate because nobody
understands everything today. Our OEMs
don't, the industry doesn't, chef isn't.
We're all on this learning journey
together. And there's no better way to
learn than to just get started. And so
the use cases we're looking at, for
example, is logistics and and carrying
uh steel uh totes over to a parts
washing machine that we paid a human
laborer to do that today. And now we've
replaced it already in one of our
manufacturing facilities with a
humanoid. And that person then is is is
somewhere else in the plant doing higher
value tests than what they were doing
before, just carrying a toad from one
side of a machine to another. Um, but we
we learned things about the color of the
floor. Is the floor shiny over here and
dull over here? And all of that had an
effect on on the robots uh sensors, for
example. The Wi-Fi stability. It was
fine for the rest of the machines in our
plants, but it wasn't good enough for a
humanoid. And so these are all things
that that we're learning now uh that
would be much more expensive to learn
later on and much more uh problematic if
we learn these later on. So we're just
diving into it, doing the homework on
the use cases and then finding partners
to to execute these use cases inside of
our plants. Mhm. So it feels like
basically because you've got this
deployment scenario and you're already
deploying this uh into your robots that
can then actually help you when you
actually develop the technology um and
from the start be able to then continue
to um iterate like is there something
particular that you've been able to
change as a result of some of your
learnings from deployment?
>> Yeah. for what we see today is is some
of the products if we talk about
actuators there may be offtheshelf
actuators or actuators are
overengineered and and a real benefit
for my team who is developing and
industrializing these components and
systems for humanoids is we can go next
door where we're deploying these and we
can actually collect data we can see
what our components actually need to do
what is the torque necessary what are
the speeds necessary is it overheating
and we have this data right in our own
house and so that kind of sharing is is
really created kind kind of an internal
uh uh flywheel development flywheel
inside of Sheffler.
>> So I think that sounds very valuable for
your partners because a lot of the
people who are building don't
necessarily readily have um those access
to those deployment environments and a
lot of this real world experience to go
and drive that. Um it's interesting
because right now you know it feels like
a lot of the work that you're doing are
you know is with humanoid robots. Uh do
you feel that that is the form factor
that is going to be um critical like
going forward? um a you know what are
your thoughts on humanoid as the form
factor? Yeah, the form factor to us and
we're really agnostic. We want to follow
a best in breed if you will. So for a
use case, what is the best application?
What is the best customer uh uh robots
out there that can do that most
efficiently and generate the most value?
And so form factor isn't so important
for us. What is a factor is we have 100
manufacturing plants and we don't need
150 or 200. to all of these dark
manufacturing plants, which there will
be some is important, but even more
important to Sheffller is how do we
convert these brownfield plants that are
already existing that were already
designed for humans. How do we make the
humanoids or the physical AI work in
these factories? And so some cases they
will need two legs and two arms. In some
cases, they will need four arms and two
wheels. Um it just depends on what the
use cases is and how the plant is set
up. I guess there are a lot of companies
that are out there that have, you know,
similar to Sha 80 years or a very long
rich history um in their particular
industries. What what advice would you
give them in terms of how to make that
leap forward? Because I think actually
you're one of the few companies that
I've come across that has really been
able to make that jump in terms of
innovation. So, um, what's different
that other people should be thinking
about because they probably have the
same pain points in terms of, uh,
challenges with the labor shortage.
Maybe it's access to the remote
environments. It feels like these are
very common problems, but I'm not seeing
a lot of companies that are actually
being as successful in terms of solving
it.
>> Yeah. And and what you're seeing is a
result of many many tries that we made,
many attempts, and they didn't always go
perfect. So, I I would always encourage
people, it starts from the top of the
house, and you need to be brave. So if
you're a COO, you're an executive here,
you need to start trying. Yes, do some
homework up front, but you can't do
homework for the next two years to try
and figure out the perfect solution and
make sure everything is covered. You
need to just try and be brave. And if
that's supported from the top of the
house, from the executive level like it
is at Shuffler, it makes it much easier.
Mhm. Um, so is there kind of like a
balance in terms of how do you trade off
against trying to innovate and build as
you fly and actually get to deployment?
Because some of the use cases that you
mentioned, it feels like you would have
invested time to actually find those use
cases. Um, you know, how what's what
makes it ready or like good enough for
you to actually be able to go and
actually start deploying in that because
that is actually a big leap, right?
So what we try to do is is we try to
identify the use cases. Then we have a
short planning phase with the customer
OEM and then we bring them in and have a
designated area where we perform this
proof of concept and and we have a great
team inside of Sheffller that does
deployment. It's our advanced production
technology team and they do this ahead
of installing it directly into a plant.
So we have robo gyms uh in the different
regions where we will test this out
first and then we will bring the PC into
the plant. So there there is a little
upfront work, there's a little lab work
that directly simulates the use case. So
we have the same machines, we have the
same conveyor belts, all of the
environment in that immediate area is
very similar to what the humanoid would
find in the plant. And then once we we
confirm that we're ready to go into the
plant, then we deploy it into the plant.
>> Uh tell me a bit more about the robo
gyms. Um, do you think that's something
that's like an absolutely critical step
for you to be able to get from um, you
know, prototype to deployment? Is that
something that's on the rise? Um, are
you building more of these robo gyms? Do
you think the industry in general will
use this as a form to get to deployment?
>> Yeah, I I think so. I think there'll be
different forms of these robo gyms. If
you look at China, this will be more
communal. So, there will be competitors
as customers that are bringing their
robots into our robo gyms. And in China,
we are creating already is is built and
and and nearly ready to open. We will
have a grand opening in October where we
will actually have a robo gym data
collection and we will produce actuators
on site for humanoids. So in theory,
customers will bring in their humanoids.
They will train our specific use cases.
They will go around the corner and build
components for themselves.
>> Okay. Well, I mean that sounds
>> that kind of flywheel is going to be
exciting. We think it's the first one
like it in the world.
>> Mhm. Um it it's interesting because I
mean it feels like now you've got it
kind of contained an environment where
you could actually do build and then
actually go and do the production and
this based in China. Um I noticed that
Sha is actually very much global. Um
you're already operating in over 50
different countries in the world. Um and
you have partnerships with companies uh
across different regions in the US,
Germany, uh France, China. Um can you
tell me a bit more about how you're
utilizing the global ecosystem and
whether there's you know any interesting
observations you have about how to work
with uh different parts of the world and
maybe what uh special areas of expertise
of innovation that they're bringing.
>> Yeah. I I go back to the speed first of
all. So no matter where we work in the
world, this industry is fast. So this is
this doesn't change really. Uh maybe
some are a little slower, some are a
little faster, but it's still coming
quite fast. uh you you see um China and
the US just because of the AI has
typically been considered the leaders
but but don't count out Europe and I
think where Europe can play a role is
especially on the safety uh but there
has to be a balance there can't be so
much safety and so much regulation that
it stifles the the humanoid or physical
AI market here in Europe because there's
a lot of companies working on it here
and we have to promote that uh in Europe
and that that's coming from a German
manufacturer. We want to see Europe
succeed. Um you see a lot more service
robots I would say in China but they
also are doing industrial robots and you
see more of a focus in the US on the uh
manufacturing uh use cases as well. So
you see a little bit of difference but
in the end it's all all fast and and
learning every day.
>> Mhm. Um I mean aside from the use cases
right so I think definitely there's
different focuses in different
geographies. Um do you feel like from a
capability or technology perspective you
also lean on different partners? um for
different areas of expertise um around
the world.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, so we have different
kinds of partners. Certainly, we have
OEM partners who who we work with and
and and share this this learning
journey, but we have uh partners like
Nvidia. And so, every day I hear uh from
my team about how we're deepening these
relationships, especially with companies
like Nvidia. With NVIDIA, for example,
we're creating digital twins of our
actuators. So if we talk about speeding
up training, reducing the sim to real
gap, part of that is going to be having
actuators simulated that actually uh are
simulated like they perform in in the
real world. And that's what we're
working on with with some of these
partners. So this partnerships that we
created, if it's from Nvidia to all of
these OEM partners, is is really
strategic and important for
>> Sheffller.
Um I guess like kind of you know looking
more forward looking, right? uh in terms
of where do you see the market heading?
Um what do you think is the next big
critical step for Shea Laura for the
physical AI market in general in order
to get to the next horizon because I
mean this year is actually the first
year of Mina. So it's you know still
very early I think for most people in
terms of thinking about physical AI
deployments. Um you know what do you see
as critical breakthroughs that maybe we
need to um get to over the next few
years? um or just how do you see it
evolving generally?
>> I I think there's really two areas. The
first one is safety.
>> So safety starts with regulations and I
just talked about bureaucracy and trying
to minimize some of this, but you need
safety standards. We
>> there's nothing more important to
Sheffller than the safety of our
employees. So we will not deploy
anything that's not safe and that does
not meet regulations and today we don't
have a lot of regulations on autonomous
robots in our plants. So any deployments
we have now are behind glass walls and
and these these humanoids uh they will
not bring value if we treat them like
zoo animals that they just stay behind
walls then we can put in a cobbot or an
industrial robot and that's not what we
want to do. So safety we need the
regulations and and we need the
community to come together to create
smart pragmatic and and safe safety
regulations. The second uh area I would
say is training. So today it takes too
long. It takes too much real data to
train robots. And so we have to get to
the point where if Shuffler receives a
robot uh or a physical AI tool from one
of our customers that it can be up and
running by Sheffller within a couple
hours and not a couple days or a couple
weeks or a couple months. So these two
breakthroughs I think will be key to to
to increasing the deployment rate. Mhm.
I think um yeah, I mean it feels like
right now definitely there is still a
very long training life cycle and you
mentioned uh the role of data. Um when
it comes specifically to data um through
all of your deployment you're obviously
accumulating a lot of data for the
training. Do you think we'll get to a
point because we're all talking about
the data shortage. We're talking about
sim to real gap. Um do you think in the
next 12 months we're going to see any
significant changes in terms of the
ability to do that? Um and is that
something that you're also working to
solve?
>> Yeah, so we have different areas trying
to solve that problem. It's not an easy
problem. I I I think the problem we have
is the data sits in different systems
inside of Sheffller. It depends on the
region. It depends on the plant and and
we have to figure out how to get that
data uh out of our systems and then
curate it into a form that we can
actually use it. And that's going to be
the the real challenge that we have uh
to to help speed up the training. But
it's something that we're working on
with several of these partners and in
different areas of our plants.
>> Um, and I guess just like the final
question because we're kind of getting
to the end of this session and the timer
is ticking. Um, but I think the safety
uh standard is very important and uh it
feels like it's an underrated kind of
topic um in terms of a lot of people are
really just building the plane as they
fly. they're not necessarily thinking
too much about um what they can do uh
and you know once you get to deployment
um do you think this is something that
uh you know Sha will be able to lead the
way in terms of building some
standardizations are you working with
partners in order to try and better
define that because I think that's
always a big conflict in terms of
building new technology um and trying to
be able to govern and um and manage it
and I think robots because they are
physically interacting with us the the
safety is absolutely critical especially
Especially if we think about going into
industrial environments uh or even into
the home.
>> Yeah,
>> it will really be solved by the
community. So, Sheffller, of course,
we're learning about safety when we
bring them into our factories, but we're
also participating uh with with
organizations that are writing ISO
standards, for example. So, not one
company can can legislate or dictate
what these regulations will be. It will
be the community that needs to do that.
And I think by participating in these
these organizations and these studies to
create these legislations and then also
understanding what we see uh boots on
the ground inside of our factories that
this puts Shuffler in a unique position
to support this.
>> All right. Well, thank you very much
David.
>> Thank you for having me. Thank you.